nous à tous
ça fait plaisir d'avoir une france pas
toujours le cas
quand on pense à ce qui peut rendre
invisible une personne on pense souvent
à la magie
y en a il ya des fans d'harry potter ici
qui vont sans doute pensé à la cape
d'invisibilité y en a d'autres qui vont
penser à un tour de magie de gérard
majax
[Musique]
mais peuvent ont pensé tout de suite ou
handicap et pourtant le handicap il a ce
pouvoir
malheureux et aléatoire de rendre
quelqu'un invisible alors un visite
comment
déjà on va prendre quelques chiffres sur
le handicap notamment en france en
france il ya 12 millions de personnes
qui sont atteintes par un handicap 2
millions sur les 67 millions
alors il ya plusieurs formes de handicap
il ya le handicap moteur il ya le
handicap sensoriel lorsqu'on perd la vue
lorsqu'on perd l'audition il ya le
handicap psychique lorsqu'on a des
troubles du comportement
il y a aussi le handicap mental avec les
déficiences intellectuelles
et ses handicaps ils ont plusieurs
origines ça peut être une origine
génétique ça peut être une origine
pathologique ça peut être une origine
accidentelle est donc une pluralité de
formes de handicap mais quand on pense
aux handicaps il ya une image qui nous
vient en tête c'est la personne en
fauteuil roulant c'est ce qui symbolise
les personnes en situation d'handicap
tout de suite si on dit handicap l'image
que vous avez en relation signifiant
signifier c'est sans doute une personne
à mobilité réduite d'ailleurs si vous
allez sur internet et que vous tapez
symbole handicap il ya de grandes
chances pour que vous ayez le petit
carré bleu avec la personne en fauteuil
roulant en blanc demain
et pourtant quand on regarde les
chiffres sur les 12 millions de
personnes en situation de handicap en
france si on n'a que 370 milles qui
utilise un fauteuil roulant
ce qui veut dire que les 11 millions six
cent trente mille autres personnes et
bah
elles sont rendues invisibles
en tout cas dans la symbolique alors
vous me direz c'est peut-être plus
facile aussi de représenter un handicap
invisible qu'un handicap dit invisible
sauf que le problème c'est que le
handicap invisible il existe bel et bien
et que si on reprend les deux millions
de personnes sur ces 12 millions là des
personnes qui sont atteintes par
handicap invisible il y en a 9 millions
ces trois personnes sur quatre en
situation de handicap et ces personnes
là du coup elles sont rendus un peu
invisible alors il ya d'autres choses
qui sociétalement rendre les personnes
en situation de handicap invisible il ya
le chômage par exemple
je sais pas si vous le savez mais il ya
enfin le chômage en france touche deux
fois plus les personnes en situation de
handicap en moyenne que les personnes
valides et pourtant l'emploi c'est quand
même un moyen assez formidable et
puissant d'interactions sociales
d'utilité dans la société on nous voit
on est visible il ya plein d'autres
manières par les handicaps de rendre les
personnes invisibles
je vais vous parler de 7,6 en vous
présentant en vous racontant une
histoire personnelle la mienne quand
j'avais 8 ans ça va donc un peu
c'était ma grand mère qui est en fait a
été diagnostiqué d'une maladie
neurodégénérative
alors comment lassus au début quels ont
été les premiers symptômes ou simplement
se balader dans les champs a commencé à
avoir des petits vertige a commencé à
trébucher beaucoup plus souvent de plus
en plus souvent parfois tomber qui au
final a pouvait même plus rester debout
au fur et à mesure du temps alors elle
était assise à la perdu l'usagé de ses
bras après c'était le buste qui bougeait
plus vraiment puis ça a été la nuque il
fallait la mettre un peu en arrière si
on l'a peut-être tomber qui après sa
remontée comme ça ça atteint le visage
donc elle a perdu la faculté de déglutir
ne pouvait plus manger on la nourrit
c'est en intraveineuse puis elle a perdu
après usage de en même temps à peu près
en même temps l'usagé de la parole
et puis ensuite à la perdu le sourire et
nous aussi
en fait assez retrouver dans une
situation où elle était totalement
enfermé dans son propre corps et il ya
plein de maladies comme ça qui amène à
cet état il ya la maladie de charcot par
exemple qu'on appelle aussi sclérose
latérale amyotrophique sla pour vous la
connaissez peut-être par stephen hawking
qui en étaient atteints le célèbre
physicien vous la connaissez aussi
peut-être par la svk challenge qui était
créée pour justement financer et
sensibiliser à la financer la recherche
contre l'asm il ya plein d'autres
pathologies à l'infirmité motrice
cérébrale il ya les myopathies il ya les
avc il ya les l'opt in syndrome la
personne qui avait
écrit le livre le scaphandre et le
papillon qui a donné ensuite un film
était à atteindre par
il ya plein de pathologies comme ça qui
amène à cet état où les personnes sont
totalement enfermées dans leur propre
corps le corps elles sont enfermées dans
leur propre corps alors qu'elles peuvent
quand même penser comme vous et moi
apple fut communiqué et je sais pas si
vous arrivez à imaginer à percevoir ce
que c'est de plus pouvoir communiquer
si aujourd'hui votre vie dans body tous
les jours vous ne parveniez plus à
communiquer
ça qu'on va faire l'expérience
ce que je vous propose c'est que vous
allez vous regarder avec votre voisin de
gauche de droite de perdre
et vous allez sans parler sans utiliser
les mains sans utiliser votre portable
sans utiliser le fond de gorge la voie
juste avec vos yeux vous allez lui
donner votre
nom j'imagine qu'en fait vous êtes venus
en groupe de potes donc vous connaissez
déjà l'année
essayez de lui dire plutôt à votre
voisin votre voisine je vous êtes très
contente d'assister à ce tedx vous allez
me dire vous êtes tous contents de
participer à cette éthique c'est presque
facile
essayez plutôt de lui faire part d'une
réflexion vous avez eu lorsque vous
aviez écouté le speech juste avant moi
donnez-lui cette réflexion partagée la
demande et lui son avis ensuite juste
avec les yeux allez-y
c'est impossible c'est clairement pas si
ce que vous venez d'expérimenter de
manière un peu ludique pendant 30
secondes c'est ce que vivent des
millions de personnes dans le monde
qui sont au quotidien
clouée dans leur lit qui ont plus du
tout la capacité de communiquer qui en
fait sont rendus invisibles parce que
lorsqu'on peut plus parler bat plus
personne vient nous parler et au final
il reste que quelques personnes avec
nous il reste les aidants qui sont
souvent la famille les proches ça
devient des aidants familiaux donc
c'était personnes qui dédient leur vie
aux proches et mai et atteint par un
handicap
et malheureusement le handicap va dans
ces situations là quand on peut plus
communiquer ça à etiolles un peu les
sentiments et sa emporte l'amour et il
ya plein de choses qui se perdent à
cause de ça et c'est profondément
injuste mais il ya quand même des
beaucoup en fait les aidants familiaux
c'est les personnes les plus courageuses
que j'aie jamais rencontré dans ma vie
vous me direz je n'ai pas encore vécu
non plus 100 ans mais je pense que je
rencontrerai d'autres personnes qui vont
m'impressionner mais celle là pour le
coup c'est vraiment des personnes les
plus altruistes et et courageuse que
j'ai pu rencontrer et il ya même des
aidants familiaux qui vont qui font face
à la fatalité et qui vont avec leurs
proches faire des projets donc j'ai en
tête par exemple pawn je sais pas si
vous connaissez un dj français alors il
était avant dans le groupe de rap la
fonky family s'il ya des anciens qui
s'en souviennent je me compte parmi les
anciens rassurez-vous
est en fait puis il il utilise un outil
qui s'appelle l'eye tracking est en fait
c'est une caméra infrarouge avec toute
une technologie derrière qui va suivre
le mouvement de la pupille sur l'écran
donc en fait là on va regarder le
curseur va se déplacer et pour
sélectionner on va se focaliser sur ce
qu'on fait sélectionner et s'appelle
sélectionnés en fait comme ça avec un
logiciel de musique il a il a composé
des albums c'est fou
avec les yeux il a même il est assez
connu pour ça maintenant il va faire
normalement la cérémonie d'ouverture des
jeux paralympiques en 2024 à paris si on
fait quand même des bonnes choses il ya
d'autres passions comme ça qu'ils
utilisent la même technologie die
tracking il ya karim brahi par exemple
qui était une artiste peintre qui a été
atteinte par là et c'est là qui
aujourd'hui pain avec les yeux il ya
damien perrier qui a atteint par là et
c'est là aussi qui écrit déroulement
avec les yeux il ya david audin par
exemple qui malheureusement nous a
quittés qui était lui aussi atteint par
la maladie de charcot et avec ses trois
fils et son épouse ils ont créé une
marque
pour financer la recherche contre la et
c'est là la marque à s'appeler espoir
je vois si
espoir c'est vraiment l'espoir des
personnes qui se dresse face au
désespoir
je vous parlais de l'eye tracking juste
avant
donc en fait on peut dire une
technologie qui existe c'est chouette
tout le monde peut l'utiliser le
problème c'est que cette technologie la
halle à plusieurs alors la marche très
bien pour ceux qui savent très bien
l'utiliser mais là plusieurs contraintes
elle peut pas être utilisé par tout le
monde selon les différences de motricité
qu'on peut avoir dans les yeux etc
elle est difficile à prendre en main
pour les personnes âgées ça sèche très
vite l'oeil de focaliser d'avoir les
yeux ouverts pour faire bouger la souris
etc c'est toujours un peu compliqué et
donc pour les le dernier point et pas
des moindres c'est que c'est très très
cher c'est très cher et c'est pas
remboursés par la sécurité sociale si ça
avait existé à l'époque de ma grand mère
on n'aurait jamais pu nous
personnellement lâcheté et donc c'est
des personnes qui font face à une double
injustice la première c'est d'être
malade est en situation de handicap et
la deuxième c'est de devoir dépenser des
sommes folles pour compenser ce handicap
c'est évidemment communiqué c'est un
fait mais il ya plein d'autres choses il
ya le fauteuil roulant il ya plein de
choses le lit
assistés pour l'hospitalisation à
domicile il ya énormément de choses à
acheter
et en fait quand on s'est rendu compte
de ça
avec sarah et pierre donc deux amis que
j'ai rencontré en école d'ingénieur on a
créé la stat la start-up wise qui a pour
vocation de développer une technologie
innovante qui permettrait la
communication et l'inclusion de tous en
un simple clin d'oeil alors pour la
petite histoire quand on a commencé
l'école d'ingénieurs nous avait donné
pour réaliser un prototype fonctionnel
une énorme subvention de 50 euros
est en fait de cette contrainte est née
quelque chose d'ultra déterminant pour
la suite c'est que ça nous a obligés
pragmatiquement à réinventer une
technologie avec des composants qu'ils
soient pas cher du tout et donc ça par
la suite ça allait la rendre accessible
parce que quand à la base on s'est dit
on va améliorer la tracking avec ce
qu'on peut déjà rim pour acheter le
composant de la caméra avant même le
reste on avait déjà pas assez d'argent
donc en fait on a récupéré
des vieilles lunettes on a enlevé les
verts on appris des capteurs infrarouges
on les a scotché dessus du scotch et des
ficelles système des ingénieurs et au
final on a réussi comme ça a créé un
premier prototype en développement en
développement des algorithmes capables
de détecter les clignements les
mouvements volontaires et de les
différencier des battements de cils
naturels
et en fait ensuite ses mouvements des
volontaires là il allait agir comme des
clics de souris comme des commandes sur
une interface laquelle on a déconnecté
halal à laquelle on allait là connectés
dont par exemple un ordinateur une
tablette un portable et du coup les yeux
vont par exemple je vais faire un
clignement de la gauche pour
sélectionner et à ossements un
rehaussement du sourcil à droite pour
revenir en arrière sauf qu'on s'est très
vite rendu compte qu'il ya des personnes
qui peuvent pas cligner d'un oeil ou qui
peuvent pas trop bouger l'autre etc et
la maladie a touché les personnes de
manière très différenciée
donc ce qu'il a fallu faire et ce qu'on
a bien fait et ce que je recommande à
n'importe quel futur entrepreneur c'est
de mettre au coeur de son projet le
futur bénéficiaire le principal concerné
est en fait nous on a on a énormément
misé sur la conception le fait de mettre
toutes ces personnes là donc les
patients les aidants le personnel de
santé des structures médicales les
associations de les mettre au coeur de
notre r&d et d'aller les voir
continuellement dès qu'on avait une
intuition nouvelles idées quelque chose
pour améliorer le prototype on en
discutait avec lui avant de le faire il
donnait d'autres idées il façonné ils
ont façonné avec nous la technologie ce
qui fait qu'à la fin on arrive avec une
technologie qui est quand même beaucoup
plus pertinente qui répond parfaitement
à leurs besoins toujours dans l'idée
ensuite de la rendre accessible
accessible dans tous les sens du terme
on parle et financièrement aussi
accessible universellement c'est-à-dire
qu'elle puisse être utilisé par
n'importe quelle personne à n'importe
quel stade de n'importe quelle maladie
et ça pour s'en rendre compte il a fallu
aller un peu plus loin que de tester
avec quelques personnes comme ça quand
vous voyez plus ou moins souvent on
s'est dit il faut tester avec un maximum
de monde de plein de pathologies
différentes et au fur et à mesure de
notre de notre avance et on a gagné
quelques concours sympa comme le
concours lépine on a été élue meilleure
innovation vise à tech 2021 quelques
prix comme ça qu'ils nous en donner de
la visibilité et puis on avait beaucoup
d'action avec des associations etc ont
poussé des personnes en fauteuil roulant
sur des semi marathon ce genre de choses
donc ça nous a donné une petite
visibilité donc il ya plein de personnes
partout en france et même d'ailleurs qui
nous demandait s'il pouvait tester les
binettes ça pouvait nous aider et
participer et ses îles nous on voulait
laisser personne sur le côté sauf que on
est à paris il y avait des personnes qui
habitent est très très loin de paris
inaccessible en train derrière des
montagnes dans les apps dans les
pyrénées bon c'était un peu compliqué et
en fait on a la chance d'avoir ça va et
pierre des personnes à qui j'ai fait ce
projet tiers il a voulu acheter une
première voiture il a investi dans un
magnifique camping-car des années 90
c'est pas donné à tout le monde d'avoir
un camping car avec un as derrière
et comme ça on a fait le tour de france
des patients en deux semaines l'été
dernier on a parcouru 4500 kilomètres
comme un peu plus on a rencontré à
quasiment 140 personnes et ça nous a
permis de tester l'universalité de notre
technologie parce qu on a rencontré
plein de personnes de plein de
pathologies on a rencontré des
associations a rencontré des hôpitaux
assez connu des gros hôpitaux on a
rencontré des plus petites structures et
ça a marché avec absolument tout le
monde est là on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait quand même une technologie
beaucoup moins cher fiable qui
fonctionne avec tout le monde donc à
partir de ce moment là de ce moment là
on a considéré que la technologie était
mature on a viabilisé davantage les les
composants etc on a revu quelques
détails électronique mécanique et on a
commencé à passer des certifications ce
moment on est en train de dépasser ce
qu'on espère c'est pouvoir rendre
disponible un premier produit d'ici la
fin de l'été de manière à ce que toutes
ces personnes là puissent retrouver une
place dans la société parce que en
communiquant c'est comme ça qu'on
retrouve sa place le fondement même de
la société c'est la communication les
sociétés se font par la communication
évidemment ce dispositif on va le vendre
à un prix accessible parce qu'il n'y a
aucune logique à développer un produit
une technologie inclusive si c'est pour
la vendre à un prix qui lui est exclusif
et tout ça c'est raccord avec la manière
dont on perçoit ce projet la manière
humaine le côté humain qu'on veut lui
offrir
et donc comme quoi en étant ingénieur on
peut aussi penser à tout ça en étant
ingénieur on peut aussi mettre au
service du commun c'est ses compétences
et je vous encourage à faire de même
vous êtes des ingénieurs en devenir
tous
vous allez réussir vos études
vous êtes des ingénieurs en devenir vous
êtes en train d'acquérir des compétences
vous allez les affermir au fur et à
mesure des années mais n'oubliez jamais
derrière que vous n'êtes pas juste des
personnels des compétences techniques
vous n'êtes pas des techniciens vous
êtes des ingénieurs et je parle pas de
technicien ou ingénieur bac + 3 à bac +
5 ça m'intéresse pas je parle de la
mentalité du paradigme un technicien il
a un projet on lui donne il exécute il
se pose pas la question il met ses
compétences techniques que au service du
projet un ingénieur il se doit d'avoir
une réflexion beaucoup plus holistique
de se poser les questions 2 pourquoi il
le fait quelles sont les conséquences
positives et négatives que peut apporter
le projet comment les endiguer ou au
contraire les favoriser c'est tout ça en
ingénieurs ça va plus loin je pense que
le modèle de l'ingénieur qui juste se
met au service d'une entreprise qui in
fine est certes des intérêts personnels
c'est un modèle qui est un peu dépassée
de plus en plus nous on est une
génération qui commence à se poser des
questions un peu plus porté sur l'impact
et je vous encourage à faire de même
parce que en faisant ça vous allez
mettre vos compétences
raccord avec votre
votre métier d'ingénieur vous allez
mettre vos valeurs au centre de tout ça
et pour finir je
vous dirais c'est une volonté que je
donne et vous partagez j'espère que vous
avez déjà prévu de suivre ce schéma là
c'est que vos valeurs c'est celle qui
vont faire parler vos idéaux et votre
idéal c'est l'utopie qui devient réel
n'ayez pas peur d'être à la fois génie
et ingénue d'avoir cette petite naïveté
qui fait que vous croyez à l'utopie que
voulait la voulait la rendre réel
je voulais en fait mettre en avant votre
idéal car ce sont vos valeurs et votre
vertu qui permettront demain
[Musique]
à votre métier d'ingénieur parce que
vous allez faire
de rendre vos vidéos palpable ou vos
idéaux pardon palpable
il ya plein de mots à dire
palm et surtout palpable inspirant et en
définitive pour être raccord avec le
thème visible merci pour votre accueil
[Applaudissements]